ja auch in deutschland gingen am
wochenende tausende bürger wieder mal
auf die straße um gegen die korona
politik zu demonstrieren in stuttgart
zogen rund 3000 personen quer durch die
innenstadt auch in erfurt versammelten
sich tausende ja und in hamburg galt
allgemeiner ausnahmezustand die
innenstadt war mit blaulicht geflutet
die stimmung ist also weiterhin
aufgeheizt aber man muss kein radikaler
impfgegner sein um endlich perspektiven
zu wollen hofft nun klarheit doch das
gegenteil ist leider der fall ja auch
der neue gesundheitsminister karl
lauterbach der quasi durch eine
bürgerinitiative zu seinem amt gekommen
ist wir erinnern uns hashtag wir wollen
karl kann die erwartungen im moment
einfach nicht erfüllen und verwirrt mit
widersprüchlichen aussagen
einerseits sagt er gestern ab man werde
öffnungs perspektiven entwickeln aber
andererseits
so lockerungen kann man zum jetzigen
zeitpunkt ausschließen wir sind mitten
in einer schweren welle mikrowelle und
wir können hier kein risiko eingehen
also widersprüchlicher aussagen sprechen
wir darüber mit bernd althusmann cdu
wirtschaftsminister und
stellvertretender ministerpräsident
von niedersachsen schönen guten morgen
herr althusmann
wird morgen herr großmann wird es
öffnungs perspektiven geben heute mittag
bei der konferenz von bund und ländern
oder bleibt alles wie es ist
man hat sich auf öffnungs perspektiven
verständigt aber eher als überschrift
weniger über inhalte denn im moment geht
es noch darum zu beobachten wie sich die
omikron variante auf die belastung des
gesundheitssystems auswirken wird von
daher haben die ministerpräsidenten
bereits im vorfeld angekündigt nicht
viel verändern zu wollen für mich steht
aber fest wenn wir erkennen können dass
omikron tatsächlich aber da wäre ich
sehr vorsichtig wirklich nur einen
leichteren verlauf hat und wir nicht an
die grenzen kommen dann müssen wir auch
sehr schnell wieder zu den bewährten
stufensystem auch bei uns in
niedersachsen zurückkehren momentan ist
es ja so dass omikron offensichtlich
doch wirklich sehr milde ist sind sie
weiterhin für eine impfpflicht in
unserem letzten gespräch hierbei bild
live hatten sie sich dafür ausgesprochen
jetzt ist klar es ist wirklich also
unseres erachtens eine mildere variante
und natürlich ist es auch so dass
wirklich auch viele menschen die eine
dreifach impfung haben auch gewusst hat
sind trotzdem an omikron erkranken
ich glaube das was die menschen in
deutschland am meisten umtreibt ist dass
die politik keinen klaren kurs hat der
bundesgesundheitsminister keine
regierungsverantwortung nicht delegieren
schon gar nicht auf die opposition und
die menschen wollen schlicht klarheit
und ich denke mit einer impfpflicht wäre
klar dass sie kommen muss das jetzt 34
verschiedene anträge im deutschen
bundestag beraten werden von gruppen und
die bundesregierung nicht in der lage
ist einen eigenen gesetzentwurf
vorzulegen zeigt aus meiner sicht
fehlende führung und von daher ich
persönlich bleibe dabei die impfpflicht
schafft klarheit sie verhindert schwere
krankheitsverläufe sie wird die
gesellschaft insgesamt schützen und es
ist mitnichten eine
gewissensentscheidung wie manche wenige
vertreter der fdp behaupten sondern aus
meiner sicht ist das interesse der
gesundheitsschutz der großen mehrheit
der deutschen bevölkerung deutlich über
zuordnung über dem einzelinteresse und
insofern glaube ich dass die impfpflicht
kommen sollte damit wir nicht ständig
wieder in weitere wellen gehen also ich
möchte nicht im herbst oder im winter
diesen jahres erneut darüber diskutieren
weil sich vielleicht eine neue variante
ergeben hat es wäre wichtig dass wir uns
jetzt gegenseitig schützen aber das ist
dann eine pflicht wie sie sagen für
etwas das vielleicht im herbst kommt und
von dem wir nicht wissen wie gefährlich
es sein wird am mittwoch mit dem
bundestag ja zum ersten mal darüber
gesprochen selbst vorsichtige biologen
wie christian drosten sagen ja wir
müssen uns letztendlich alle mit dem
virus infizieren um aus dieser pandemie
heraus zu bekommen warum dann noch eine
impfpflicht
in dieser frage stimme ich dann trösten
so nicht zu auch wenn er unzweifelhaft
experte in fragen der gesundheit und des
impfens ist ich nicht aber ich glaube
wir haben bisher von dem großteil der
experten die auch wir befragen immer und
immer wieder erklärt bekommen dass nur
impfen am ende schützt von
krankheitsverläufen nicht vor
infektionen ich muss sagen wir haben ein
kommunikationsproblem auch als politik
gegenüber der bevölkerung dass das
vielleicht zu wenig deutlich geworden
ist impfen schützt jetzt nicht vor
möglicher infektionen es schützt vor
schweren krankheitsverläufen und omikron
hat sich verwandelt delta sind wir
nahezu durch aber es bleibt fakt wir
laufen auf an der situation zu wo wir
haben 19 jahren 119 januar noch 100000
in sidenten hat man vermutlich mitte
februar
400.000 werden immer noch türkisch dann
möglicherweise einige hundert wenn nicht
sogar über 1500 tote zu beklagen mit und
ancona erkrankte die dann daran sterben
also die situation ist noch nicht so aus
meiner sicht dass wir in rhel entwarnung
geben können aber sollte das sein dann
muss die politik den mut haben sehr
schnell zu sagen was noch
verhältnismäßig erscheint und was nicht
darauf bereitet sich die heutige
ministerpräsidenten vor weil ich das
beschlusspapier
etwas zurückhaltend formuliert als eine
allgemeine beschreibung empfinde dessen
was man tun könnte sollte müsste politik
erwarten die menschen in deutschland
erwarten von der politik klare handlung
klare haltung und klare führung und das
findet im moment und das muss durch den
bund kommen aus meiner sicht nicht
ausreichend stadt sagt bernd althusmann
stellvertretender ministerpräsident und
cdu mitglied damit ein
oppositionspolitiker wenn man so will
und vielen dank herr althusmann
wer was erwartest du denn heute mehr
haltung nein ich erwarte dass es
tatsächlich beschreibend bleibt wie herr
althusmann es gesagt hat der expertenrat
der bundesregierung hat ja wieder eine
stellungnahme herausgegeben da ist keine
empfehlung ausgesprochen dafür dass man
jetzt die maßnahmen verschärft oder
lockert die bundesregierung der
bundeskanzler olaf scholz sieht das
genauso deshalb wird hier und da
nachjustiert war der kontakt nach
verfolgung bei den pcr tests aber ich
glaube
stand jetzt dass wir neue maßnahmen oder
auch lockerungen nicht zu erwarten haben
der gesetzentwurf wird mit einer
möglichen überlastung des
gesundheitssystems
begründet aber mit medizinische gründe
werden dafür überhaupt nicht aufgeführt
genauso spricht jetzt von der
impfpflicht der erste antrag der bekannt
geworden ist von den impfpflicht
befürworten unter anderem vom grünen
politiker janosch dahmen und das hat
mich auch wirklich überrascht die
impfpflicht für alle ab 18 soll kommen
um eine mögliche überlastung des
gesundheitswesens wie wir sie bislang
übrigens noch nicht hatten in
deutschland auch in den kommenden wellen
zu verhindern und das wundert mich weil
ehrlich gesagt ab 18 bräuchte ist
pflicht dann nicht weil die 18 19 20
gegen auch die 30 und 40 jährigen waren
nicht dafür verantwortlich dass die
gesund dass die das gesundheitswesen
belastet wurde die kommen nämlich
meistens einfach nicht auf den
intensivstationen da sind vor allem
ältere menschen und auch ganz viele
andere fragen sind da nicht beantwortet
beispielsweise dass wir jetzt eine
wahrscheinlich eine im märz/april ende
sehr hohe durchseuchung haben werden wir
werden ein großteil der bevölkerung
haben der geimpfte ist auch dreifach
geimpft und den zweiten teil der
wahrscheinlich komplett durchläuft sein
dass zumindest das was die experten
sagen und sind wir uns dann wirklich
sicher dass dieser schutz denn auch eine
omikron infektion bietet auch vor
weiteren wellen überhaupt nicht lass uns
noch mal ganz kurz auch über den mangel
an pcr test sprechen auch das ist großes
thema momentan ist können jetzt nur noch
die getestet werden dies auch wirklich
nötig haben was ist denn zum beispiel
mit leuten die jetzt in urlaub fahren in
urlaub fliegen wollen wo ja auch
pcr-test benötigt werden die bleiben auf
der strecke genau und werde das zu
verantworten dass das teil zum mangel
gibt genau die haben einfach pech gehabt
wir haben uns lange auf pcr tests
verlassen pcs das war sozusagen der
goldstandard also jeder aber viele
kennen das vermutlich wenn sie mal einen
positiven schnelltest haben dass man
sich denkt na ja vielleicht ist er ja
falsch positiv also vielleicht bin ich
gar nicht infiziert und dann macht man
zur sicherheit einen pcr-test und erst
wenn der pcr test positives dann wird
man auch als corona fall gezählt dann
geht man in quarantäne und so weiter und
so fort das wird jetzt alles nicht mehr
gemacht werden können für die breite
gemeint war wir uns auf so genannte wohl
eine radlergruppe konzentrieren und oft
mitarbeiter von krankenhäusern und
ehrlich gesagt haben wir es einfach in
zwei jahren von demi wieder einmal
verpasst die kapazitäten auszubauen also
in anderen ländern wird deutlich mehr
getestet um ein vielfaches mehr getestet
als in deutschland wir haben zwar
schnelltests aber uns wurde auch immer
gesagt achtung mit dem schnelltest
glaubt den nicht zu sehr macht so sich
hätten pcr test und jetzt plötzlich wo
die infektionszahlen sind so so hoch wie
noch nie da muss der gesundheitsminister
der jetzt ja auch seit über einem monat
im amt ihr sagen wir haben die pcr test
kapazitäten in der tat ein großes
problem insbesondere auch für reisende
die halt irgendwie an frischen pcr-test
vorweisen müssen und dass dann womöglich
nicht mehr können weil er eben
priorisiert ausgegeben wird oder sie
werden unfassbar teuer momentan liegt er
sogar 300 euro wenn man ihnen 34 stunden
haben möchte dann könnte ich mir
vorstellen dass die preise dann noch
einmal enorm steigen vielen dank für den
fiat auf